Hello everybody. Welcome to another zoom call. I don't know where everybody is located. We're in a little bit blizzard.
So crazy weather here at least we're supposed to have blizzard out conditions tomorrow and Friday, so understand if you do place it order for supplements.
I don't want to center so
All right, just to remind her that casting all our cares upon him harder to do. We're having struggles and might seems to be turning us upside down, but it's what we need to do when we stay faithful.
Reminder that starting in January, we're going to drop back down to one zoom call. We're actually not really because we're going to add a protocol zoom call.
So I have that on the zoom call page. I should have taken a screenshot of that too.
So we're going to add a protocol zoom call. It's just going to talk about protocols, but it's in a maybe on Mondays and noon, but I'm letting you guys kind of decide that.
So please send me in the question box on the bottom of the member site when you would like to have a zoom call. Maybe it's going to be Monday at 7 p.m. Maybe it's going to be, I don't know, whatever works for you guys.
I'll just kind of take it, you know, a kind of a poll and pick what's going to work best for you. I don't mind doing it in the evening. So, so give me your ideas about when you'd like to do that.
Like everybody's been on the calls to know that the state laws have changed, and they're just really buckling down on any kind of practices like mine.
They will not allow the interstate one on one calls. They just don't allow that anymore. It was, it was allowed during COVID and things were really wax about that, but now the power to be just want to control everything.
And they're just getting worse. It's getting to be like 1950, AMA, you know, shutting down all the Mexico, setting down the cancer clinics that were doing.
Then we're doing anything like due to pseudophils and things like they shut down hoxie and they shut down right for they shut down.
Gerson that that became the Mexico cancer, but it's well that's what they're trying to do now. So we're trying to do everything we can just to stay within our guidelines.
And I know multiple other practitioners like myself that do very similar things that cancer, but similar things that you'll try to help people with thyroid issues and things like that.
And they are getting the same thing. So they're getting letters from the state boards. And I know a number of you have emailed me saying, Hey, I want to fight this. I want to help this is just so ridiculous. I'm sick of being in this totalitarian government that's, you know, taking over our country.
I want to write letters to my senators. I want to call the state boards. Well, I appreciate that. I really, really do it. I think that's how you do get grassroots changes.
Please don't use our name. It just will probably cause more fire on our head.
It's hard thing is you can't call your boards, but you could talk to senators. You could talk to Congress and you could talk to your governor.
I don't know. It's going to change anything because I had to be so cynical. But they are literally in, you know, there.
How they get elected is the neutral or the pharmaceutical companies basically give them money for their election. So it's just, it's just a system we live in. We just need to be either what this does is should draw us back to God.
And to know that, you know, we continue to do what he's calling you continue to try to fight the good fight.
Sometimes fighting the good fight is fighting legal battles against the powers that be.
And sometimes fighting the good fight is trusty that God's going to deal with those kind of things that we need to just kind of keep helping people.
That's the approach we've taken through a lot of prayer.
We just want to keep helping people. So if I get into a giant legal battle with the state boards.
I can literally get thrown to jail or something. I don't know worst case scenario. I guess I could be fine down in business or something like that.
And I just don't, I just want, I just don't feel like that's the direction that's leading. We're just going to try to abide by their requirements.
And we're going to, and I know they're going to get tighter as the years go by.
But we're just going to keep doing what we need to do in order to help people.
So I could help people. I believe just as much doing zoom calls as I can doing what I love calls. It's really very, very few people.
This, and that are that were members patients of ours that even requested one of the one calls. Some of you that are on this call, but.
So it's going to affect those few people, but we can still help people just as much on one of the ones close.
No, there will be close the day after Christmas. Therefore, there'll be no zoom call next Monday.
So last Monday, two days ago was the last Monday zoom call. And then we're going to pick a new day for our protocols.
So January, we're adding the protocols. So give me suggestions on what day and time you prefer for that.
So please put it in central time. Please understand where central time.
Okay, let's get to the questions.
This person at hospital treatment recently, blood transfusion and hemoglobin, it had both stopped with the transfusion had a CT scan, the tumor had grown.
And it's pressing on the jugular. That's what they were thinking that it was pressing on the aorta and the jugular. That's why it wasn't operable.
And it looks like especially on the jugular, it's blocking that flow on the right side of the neck.
They feel as the tumor grows and will continue to bleed and eventually press too hard on the chroniter artery or the jugular, and it could burst the oncologist says can be days, weeks or whatever for this to happen.
He was, the patient was putting the right but his stomach or chest. Can he run the tumor all run on the tumor all night? Yes, you can put it up close to the cancer.
It's close to the tumor as possible, the better that's my belief.
And he should be running the programs that we made for him. Will this cause die off to be too fast? No, I don't think so.
So please keep this person in your prayers.
And I just hope that all of you are praying for each other. I think, and you know that I'm praying for you constantly going to.
There's a clot in his brain. What right programs should you use for clots?
So what right programs should use for clots? There's not specific programs for clots, but there is a circulation stasis program that's 40 minutes that would be a good program to use for clots.
You want to look at nutrition like natozyme and lumbrosine natozyme is nato kinase and lumbrosine is lumbro kinase. Those are two enzymes that have been found to help to help kind of gobble up clots.
So that would be good nutrition, the same nutrition that I would recommend if you had clots due to, you know, anything, any reason for having love clots, I would do natozyme and lumbrosine.
I would be taking, if you know you have a clot, I'd be taken probably six a day of each of them. It's an enzyme you cannot overdose on these enzymes, but.
They believe the HPV type of cancer responds well to radiation. However, due to the tuber size, now they feel there's nothing to cure him. Radiation chemo may shrink it down, but it's confident it would, would not get rid of the entire tumor.
And we had discussions about this one one calls previously, we talked about where the cancer isn't how large it is. You could probably shoot through and not have any damage to other tissue.
So I think that would be a good idea to talk about that several weeks ago and months ago.
How to annual colonoscopy, the doctor said my rectal tumor has nearly doubled in size. I have been following your protocol to the best of my ability. What else would you recommend?
Make sure that you're that you're running the right this often as you can. Number one, put the ball right down between your legs. Number two.
And then for our nutritional protocol considered doubly the black sand blood road. Black sand blood road can be really effective for colo rectal tumors. And then consider adding the.
Dr. Kelly's Dr. William Kelly's on protocol for enzymes, which would be the digestime plus enzyme by US enzyme with 15 or 20 caps on a waking and a 15 or 20 caps before bed.
I know that's a lot, but if you really follow Dr. William Kelly's protocol with the enzymes that he had available in the 1960s and 70s.
You'd be taking 100 caps, 100 capsules in the morning, 100 capsules at night.
That's almost a undoable. So, but that's really the Dr. Kelly protocol. Now the enzymes that digestimes that we have now are fermented type enzyme much more powerful than Dr. Kelly's original enzyme protocol.
So you can get by with taking less, but you have to keep it about 30 minutes away from food. You want to want these to get down there and not be absorbed, but to digest that tumor. So that's the whole idea of of Dr. Kelly's protocol is the enzymes are breaking up the tumor.
So Dr. Kelly's protocol understand can be beneficial for any cancer, but really for liver, for a pain, and for, you know, cold stomach, colorectal, you know, the intestinal type cancers. That's really where it shines.
If you're getting the impression that if I want some updated, I think they meant collegiology testing, I should get up to your clinic for a personal visit as soon as possible before they shut you down completely.
I don't have any fear that they're going to shut us down completely. They just don't have the authority to do that. So that's not an issue whatsoever.
So you don't have to worry about that. We're going to still be here.
It's not even that doesn't even enter to my mind. So I do think is that accurate over action. It's an overreaction. However, we don't do in office.
It's an easy allergy visit. So we're, that's, that's not an option for us. That's not because they're going to shut us down. So we created those protocols.
Follow this protocols. Use this. If you want an update to your protocol, like I can take you this, there's already anything else I should add.
We're going to have to ask that on a group visit. It's just that's their rule. We have to do things as a group.
Here's here's an example. Okay, not to get too technical into this whole fight with the board and what they're trying to do is they can't do anything when we teach it a group.
Well, we teach it a group of falls under free speech education. So there's no way this is ever going to shut down until we turn into a communist country, which is not looking great.
But it's another story. So as long as we stay teaching in a group, I could give very specific instructions on what I would do because it's an educational format. If I'm doing one on one, then I'm doing.
Then I'm practicing medicine. And that's what we can't do. So as long as we do it in a group, you can ask whatever personal question you wanted. If you ask it on the member site, of course, nobody knows who asked this question.
That effect. I don't remember who asked this question. So I'm just copying and pasting these questions into this PowerPoint and then going through this. And I don't remember.
Many times I don't even read the question till we're on this call. So it's it's very anonymous. So keep asking very personal questions on this site.
I'll update on Anne and AJ. Well, Anne will has given me permission to share about AJ. AJ is her 20 now, your old son, who was diagnosed with the cute Milo leukemia just a couple months ago.
It was not doing real well. He went through multiple rounds of chemos doing much better, and he's thought to be in a deep remission. However, he is following a protocol from the University of Minnesota that is
required to do this very, very heavy, evil one week, out of the month for three months. And he's in the middle or at the end of his first week and it's really knocking him for a loop.
So please be praying for him to thank you.
He's been praying for Anne and the family too.
You know, what would anybody's going through difficult times? It's just as hard or harder on the family than the person.
And we all have to keep that in mind with our conditions that, you know, maybe we're the ones suffering physically, but it's other people's that people that are love us dearly that are suffering emotionally.
Just tested positive for COVID any suggestions.
You can run the COVID programs on the right. I know this person probably had to get tested because this person had to go in for some type of therapy in the hospital so they tested it.
Certainly, if you had a choice, you're not getting tested for COVID. You understand the test for COVID is completely unreliable to the point of it actually being a joke.
So, but if you're forced to get tested for COVID and, you know, then, and forced to get treated for it, you know, I mean, that's, that's your choice.
Certainly, I wouldn't take any, even if I was early second, I'd take either mectin or hydroxychloroquine, certainly be taking nutrition, certainly be taking our clear CV, which is probably just the best collection of this really created for COVID, the clear CV is the product.
But definitely be ready to COVID programs done in life.
I did a group session in one and one with Megan yesterday and lots of emotional work also was on the right for about three hours while on the zoom call with her.
I felt good when I woke up this morning, but after my coffee, I had lots of crampied and blood in the stool.
The blood is mucusy and stringy, if that makes sense. Still having crampied this afternoon, feels like dry heaves and stomach, my stomach or colon.
I just finished up my third row, the bed is all four days on three days off, and I grew mectin five days on two days on yesterday.
What if this could be an emotional release or a detox reaction could that's all that's those are possible for sure.
Don't rule out that you might have a little bug or something to maybe you got a little flu or something to so it goes back to, you know, I know we're not feeling good.
But we always, you know, with quite anything to our disease, but better remember that there's, you know, we can have other things going on too.
I'd definitely be taking, you know, more immune stimulants or something like that, getting your rest, you know, drinking some tea, just taking it easy, trying to treat it as if you have something that you need to take care of yourself with, obviously.
About down.
Maybe I don't know, you know, so this person one and one session with negative are talking about yet back then, Zell who does emotional help with emotional clearing and dealing with deep emotional emotional root causes, who we refer people to.
I'm so certainly could be tied to that too.
Is it okay to do coffee enemas while I am taking eyebrows or should I do them.
On my seven day break, I have been doing them three days a week.
I would say you could continue to take off to coffee enemas while doing eyebrows. I don't think there's an issue there.
Do I have to wait a few days after getting my Zelletta and basil basil next before going to the sun?
I don't know, I think you'd be going to wait 24 hours, but I don't think you need to wait, you know, more than that.
Can you tell me if burberry would be would affect the benefit me if so, how much?
So for those who listen to me very long, I'm a huge fan of burberry.
Burberry has, you know, so many health benefits.
If you don't have, you know, cancer, burberry is one of the best killers.
H. Pylori, which has, has at least a huge comorbidity with anybody with cancer.
Anybody with heart disease, you have to kind of expect that you have H. Pylori issues.
So burberry and huge killer of H. Pylori.
Burberry is a great immune stimulator. There's tons of articles on burberry and cancer.
There's also,
tons of information of burberry lowering blood sugar.
So the burberry can be great to lower blood sugar, which could help cut off the fuel source of the cancer as well.
So burberry, as I'm a huge fan of it, I use the Burberry clear of the reason why we have the Burberry clear as a private label was it also has awful pay a cast at it.
Which is such a great antioxidant. So,
Burberry clear taking, you know, two to three a day would be appropriate.
It's just a great product for so many things.
Is there a rife setting for someone who lost their sense of smell from COVID about a year ago?
Well, there's a right, there's a COVID long haul program. I would try that one.
The COVID long hauler, I think it's called.
That's the one I would use.
Don't think there's, you can look.
I think there's another program for loss of smell, you'd have to look it up.
I don't, I don't think there is. I would do the COVID long haul program.
Okay, for the chat. Hi, is 100% pure turpentine for a parasite would help for anal cancer.
Well, there is a turpentine protocol for cancer. I know people know what?
Yeah, there is a turpentine protocol for cancer.
And turpentine was actually used to treat a lot of diseases back before before pharmaceuticals came on it.
And then it slapped that, you know, so I don't know what that protocol is.
You'd have to Google that. I don't know what that is.
But, you know, don't disclose some of these these kind of old school protocols for different things.
You know, a lot of them did it's work and we're fully, but a lot of them did work.
So, I just talked to somebody on the phone or about it, maybe two months ago, that was doing the turpentine protocol for cancer.
I was doing it for a while and they thought that's what was helping them along.
That's the first time I talked to somebody doing that for cancer for a couple of years.
Is there something to help bring up white blood cells and red blood cell codes after chemo?
Well, your red blood cell codes are beat up after chemo, because chemo kills everything that's a problem.
And really, the only thing that's going to really help with that is, you know, doing, I heard it and,
and vitamin B12.
Your white blood cell codes bring it up white blood cell is all your immune stimulants.
So everything that you're currently taking is an immune stimulant, which is so many things on your protocol, you know, just keep pushing those to build that up.
Make sure you're getting rest for sure.
That's important to get your white blood cell contact too.
If you're stressing yourself, so think about adaptogens to help with stress after chemo, too, and be just running your right.
There is an immune stimulant program on the right that I tell you know that I have it in your overnight programs.
So you can run that. I don't think it's a long program. I look for immune stimulation. I think it's called.
Well, this recording be available tonight. Yes, I will have it up tonight on the, on the bedversight.
All right, any other questions?
Well, then I will say goodbye a little early today.
So I could get home for that before the Blizzard hits.
Is he would go and find it 9.8? Well, it's still low, but it's not, if you're not critical or anything like that.
Well, they won't do a transfusion. It will give you blood until you're at 7.5 or 7.0 at some hospitals.
They don't see that as critical. I'll tell you're done.
So yeah, 9.8, you might be tired.
Have some fatigue, but they're not a critical state by any stretch of an agitation there.
All right, please be prayed for each other, you guys.
And yeah, I won't see you till after Christmas. We celebrated Christmas this last week with our family. So yeah, Christmas is Sunday.
Have a very, very Christmas.
Do you remember what Christmas is all about?
Keep that in your hearts.
Know that I prayed for you, and I love you all about them.